This is Peter Cooper from the NCBI.
Today's webinar is about the RefSeq Functional
Elements project and Catherine Farrell, one
of the RefSeq people will be talking about
that.
And all the questions, even if we don't know
the answers now we will find them out and
put them in a Q&A document.
Okay I'm going to turn this over to Catherine.
Hello, everyone.
This is Catherine Farrell from the RefSeq
project . Here I am showing you the RefSeq
homepage.
To talk specifically about the RefSeq Functional
Elements part of the project that is highlighted
here . before I do that I would like to remind
you of what the RefSeq scope has been so far
we have been annotating genes which can either
be protein coding or non-coding.
And the RefSeq accessions have prefixes like
NM_, or NP_s for proteins, or XM_s and XP_s
for model accessions that are protein coding.
NR_s or XR_s for non-coding transcripts.
We have also been annotating Pseudogenes,
which can be transcribed or non-transcribed.
The non-transcribed ones get NG_ accessions.
We have also been annotating genomic regions
or segments with NG_ accessions.
These have been typically regions containing
multiple genes or segments such as immumoglobulin
genes.
We also have RefSeqGene representations for
clinically relevant gene regions.
They are used as a foundation for variant
reporting.
All of these are conventional gene type annotations
. however there are some points we need to
bear in mind.
Only 1.1% of the human genome is protein coding.
Less than 2% of the genome has conventional
gene type annotation when you include non-coding
genes and Pseudogenes genes along with protein
coding genes.
It is also known from research, particularly
GWAS studies, that a lot of disease-associated
variation occurs in the non-coding genome.
That leads us to the question of what other
functional content is present in the eukaryotic
genome?
There are gene regulatory elements such as
enhancers, silencers, promoters, TF binding
sites and locus control regions, such as this
example shown here.
There are also structural elements including
boundary elements, matix attachment regions
and other structural regions associated with
chromatin confirmation.
There are also elements involved in other
regulatory processes such as DNA recombination
or repair, DNA replication, or chromosome
maintenance or stability.
It is known that variation in all of those
regions can result in disease.
Also, higher order chromatin structure and
epigenetic modifications are important for
these functional processes.
With that in mind we decided to annotate RefSeq
functional elements . The project overview
has this workflow where we would take known
elements that have been well-defined and experimentally
validated in the literature and data from
pubmed to curate the records, as well as data
from databases such as the VISTA enhancer
database that has experimentally validated
enhancers and we would also use data from
collaborators to and enhance the experimentally
validated data when necessary.
The curated records would be of two types.
One would be a record in the Gene database
which would contain metadata.
I will demonstrate that later.
We would also produce a RefSeq record in NCBI's
Nucleotide database.
Those records are used to release FTP downloads
on NCBI's websites and they are used in NCBI
genome annotation and available on genome
browsers.
What is the scope of the RefSeq functional
element project ? First I would like to give
the definition of non-genic functional elements.
That is any genomic element that has functional
significant based on experimental support
and is not otherwise considered to be a conventional
gene.
The types that we represent include gene regulatory
elements such as enhancers, silencers, promoters
and structural elements known as boundary
elements, matrix attachment regions and other
elements of functional importance for example,
well-defined or clinically significant recombination
hotspots or DNA replication origins.
Our annotation scope are for elements is that
elements have to be experimentally validated
in the literature, and we're only representing
human and mouse elements right now, with some
prioritization for elements implicated in
human disease.
I also want to point out what RefSeq functional
elements are not going to represent, and that
is, we are not representing predicted or imputed
elements from large-scale epigenetic studies
such as those covered in other resources such
as the ENCODE or NIH Roadmap Epigenomics projects
or the Ensembl Regulatory Build. in addition
the elements we represent are not as restrictive
as those in those other resources with respect
to element types.
We can include element types that cannot be
readily predicted by epigenetic mapping studies
alone.
An example would be recombination regions
or gene regulatory elements that are hard
to find by a particular experimental type
such as locus control regions.
It is also important to remember that since
this is a new data set and we just had a initial
release that this data set is not yet complete,
so you may not find your favorite gene regulatory
element in the database at this point in time.
Now I would like to describe the genomic RefSeqs
that we are making for these functinal elements
. these will have NG_ accession prefixes.
They will span the genomic range of one or
more experimentally validated functional elements,
where we are grouping closely situated and
highly regulated elements together.
For example, a cluster of enhancers that regulate
the same gene will be included on the same
NG accession . All of the accessions will
be associated with an NCBI BioProject accession
as shown here.
You will identify those records on the flatfile
at the top.
There will be a DBLINK to the bio project
accession.
We will also include a parental region feature
on all of those records which will be marked
as a biological region such as this example
on the flatfile.
All of these records will have a lot of feature
annotation.
All features are in accordance with INSDC
specifications.
Shown here is the INSDC website and their
feature table that defines and lists all the
definitions that they have.
We are also using controlled vocabularies
from the Sequence Ontology when the INSDC
feature is not very descriptive . Such as
if it is just called a misc feature, -- miscellaneous
feature, we will use Sequence Ontology terms
such as this example, conserved region.
We also want to include experimental qualifiers
on other features to indicate the type of
experimental evidence that exists for the
feature.
We want to include at least one evidence call
from the Evidence and Conclusion Ontology.
That is called a ECO ID.
As shown in the highlighted example.
We also want to include at least one citation
from PubMed, so users can click on the PMID
link and see the publication on those records.
We are also using other INSDC qualifiers on
the feature annotation when applicable.
Such as feature class qualifiers and those
apply to both regulatory class features such
as this example shown here or a recombination
class feature such as a meiotic recombination
hot spot example as shown here.
We also include note qualifiers which are
details from the literature as shown in this
example, and we also include db_xref qualifiers
to cross-reference database records.
This example shows the cross-reference to
the gene ID for this particular RefSeq . There
will be other qualifiers for certain features
such as a bound moiety for protein bind features,
Or if a function is known for a particular
feature we can also indicate details for those.
Now I will describe the Gene records that
we are representing.
The Gene record is a central location with
integrated data from various resources.
Here is an example of one such record.
Here I would like to point out the top part
where we have a gene type called biological
region for all of these records.
We are also going to display feature types
based on the feature annotation on the associated
RefSeq.
We also display other information such as
symbols and aliases from the literature as
well as a RefSeq summary that gives summary
of what the region is and what type of elements
are involved in that particular region.
We also show links to ortholog records, and
if there is one in the mouse ortholog.
The gene record also contains other curated
areas, including a citations section with
a link to PubMed with related publications,
or Related sequences.
The gene record also contains a feature annotation
graphic display.
Right now the gene annotation is not showing
automatically by default because we only have
the annotation done in an NCBI interim annotation.
I would like to draw your attention to the
Tracks button on the top right where you would
need to turn on the Configure page and turn
on these particular tracks that are marked.
And these show up on the browser like this.
In the biological regions track you would
see all of the feature annotations for the
particular region.
Those features are color-coded according to
INSDC classifications.
If you mouse over the title of one of those
features such as the locus control region
feature, you can bring a pop up box full of
information about that feature . that will
include all of the qualifiers previously described
such as the experiment qualifier with links
to PuMed IDs and you can also turn on the
links to sequence if you want to obtain that
sequence from there.
Here I am showing a least of feature keys
and feature classes and other controlled vocabularies
we have used so far.
These are a list of features that have appeared
on the NCBI's human interim annotation.
I want to point out that many of our features
are regulatory class features.
We have a particular high amount of enhancer
features.
We also have a lot of misc_recomb features.
Most of those are either meiotic recombination
hotspots or they are non allelic homologous
recombination regions.
We also have several protein binding sites
that are experimentally validated in the literature.
The current genome annotations status as mentioned
previously is based on interim annotations
and we have that data available in GFF3 format
on the FTP site as well as in NCBI graphical
view tracks as I showed two slides ago.
We have that for both human and mouse.
Here is an example of our ftp site for the
human annotations.
You need to go to that particular path to
find the file.
And the highlighted file is the most recent
interim annotation.
Our future plans are to do a full NCBI genome
annotation for human and mouse . we expect
the human annotation to be released late this
year within the next month or so.
We continue to do more curation to produce
more functional element records.
We will provide links of gene targets for
particular elements or links of elements that
interact with each other in our gene records
. we will also provide links to Ensembl Regulatory
Build accessions that overlap RefSeq functional
element features . we are also working with
USCSC to provide a UCSC Genome Browser track.
More information is available on our website
. I would like to point out the data access
sections where you can find a lot more information
on how to access the data.
You can access it via Gene, Nucleotide, BLAST,
BioProject and NCBI databases as well as the
graphical displays and FTP sites . finally,
I would like to remind you to stay tuned to
the NCBI Insights blog and NCBI social media
for future announcements about RefSeq Functional
Elements.
Thank you for listening . if there are any
questions
Thanks very much Catherine, this is Peter
Cooper again.
We'll leave the questions pods open for a
few minutes if you have any questions please
type them in.
There do not seem to be any questions right
now.
But if you have any questions about the material
we talked about today you can write to our
helpdesk . the address is, info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
If you have any questions about the webinars
series, write to, webinars@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
Thank you for coming.
We're going to end the webinar now.